okay
we are live
thank you
uh
for that and good evening everybody i
don't think i've ever been in a meeting
with quite so many officers in
attendance
so a wealth of officers so thank you
everybody for attending
um
could i ask everybody to check that
their mobile phones are turned off
please
and um i'm certain that uh none of you
needs me to
that none of you needs me to tell you
the significance of the
times
we are in in our country this week
i would like this meeting to to mark the
very sad passing of her majesty queen
elizabeth ii
by observing one minute of silence and i
would appreciate you joining in
please stand if you are able to
thank you thank you very much
only our friends at microsoft that
managed to interrupt but
they know their place in doing such
things
so
welcome to
tonight's
meeting of health scrutiny committee
could i remind everybody that um
if you wish to speak uh we need you to
use the microphones
in order for that to go out on the
on the internet coverage
um
so we need to note the attendances uh i
have a apologies from
councillor akinola and
councillor denise weston
or other idea other
apologies
sorry
julius lloyd
and councillor slade such
and cancel us later
[Music]
thank you uh item two is decorations of
interest
members need to give notice of any
interest in the nature of that interest
relating to any item on the agenda
i don't know if
anybody needs to do that there's usually
some health service
ones but they're not here today
okay thank you
nhs right
okay thank you if we can record that as
appropriately
um
the minutes of the meeting held on the
28th of june have been supplied can we
uh agree those as a correct record
okay thank
you uh item for us questions from the
public and there are none
uh item five is the ultra minor injuries
unit um
so this
is an item that we
um
opened up in effect at our last meeting
and um
and that followed um members being aware
of a lot of concern from members of the
public about quite what was happening at
the ultra minor injuries unit with it
being closed
for for such a long time
so
today we're receiving a report from the
director of commissioning for trafford
and nhs greater manchester integrated
care
and who's you have to say that
[Music]
there's a few
few of us that are doing the
presentation today so we'll do some um
introductions first and then we're we're
splitting the presentation between us in
terms of giving you the update that you
asked for chair around the the current
situation around doctoring minor
injuries and plans for standing it back
up again and then also a
report or a request to scrutinate it for
some support around a longer term review
around urgent care as well so um i'm
naomi ladwig i'm the director of
commissioning
mhs trafford as part of nhs gm
helen is with me
too
so i'm i'm helene i'm deputy director of
public health at trafford yeah and we've
got some colleagues from mft over on the
other side of the table as well
so john waring directs a strategy from
mft
hi i'm sarah perkins interim chief exec
for within short trafford altering him
and whithington
and jane grimshaw director of nursing
for wooden shore trafford altrum and
woodington thank you
so i'll just take you through some
background just to make sure we're we're
all starting off from the same starting
point so um altering a minor injuries
unit is based at the ultron hospital
and the purpose of the minor injuries
unit is to treat as it says on the tin
minor injury so that includes broken
limbs simple bites and wounds
minor burns cuts and lacerations and
importantly it's not able to accept
patients who present with illnesses such
as cough colds headaches um or any more
serious illnesses they they would be
treated within other urgent care
settings um within trafford and across
our borders as well
and the general open in ours uh prior to
the stand down in april 2020 were eight
to eight monday to friday um and ten
until six at weekends and it was closed
for public holidays
um in response to the pandemic it was um
stood down um in april 20 um 2020 to be
able to support workforce um
flow within uh the within show site and
the team from mft we'll go through that
in a little bit more detail whenever we
come to um the next slide
um and it was stood back up again in
june 2021 but at reduced capacity
because of the again of the workforce
issues
um and it had to stand down again in
july 2021 um again because of the
workforce issues and during this time
and the emp staff which is the extended
nurse practitioners or the emergency
nurse practitioners were redeployed to
support work at with and shaw
we've previously shared a briefing to
scrutiny on this um and also about where
the ongoing um suspension would would
head to and we promised we would come
back and bring an update in in autumn
2022
um and we're where we've got a proposal
within the slide deck that will take you
through about the stand up but as i say
it's it's couched within that kind of
wider needs assessment and looking at
the overall urgent care needs within
trafford
so if i just move on i think i'm
probably stating the obvious whenever i
say that altering a minor injuries is a
service that's valued by the people of
altering them and known for quick and
easy access
we know that previously constituents
have raised concerns regarding not only
the loss of the altering and minor
injuries but loss of actually altering
them itself as a hospital
with mps and counsellors um
again we've we've got um information
within the slides that
are in the paper that you receive within
the pack that take us through um what is
in altering them as well so there's
there is more than just the altering of
minor injuries there's the phlebotomy
services outpatient services and renal
dialysis as well so it's a well used
hospital and and it continues to be in
the strategic direction of both mft and
also the the commissioners within the
nhs gm as well
in terms of um prior to closure within
altering
minor injuries the chief complaint
where people presented to the injury
unit was
upper and lower limb injuries
so broken or sprained or hurt arms and
legs and there was a high
high incidence of children within that
as well so and children between the age
of five and nine and ten and four
predominantly were those that present
although there were people across all
ages that present it into the unit
sorry miss slight my um computer's on a
go slow
in terms of um where people um live who
attend altering minor injuries it's a
very very tight um cordial of where
people attend so just over 50 percent
live within 1.5 miles of ultra minor
injuries and 73 traveled to 2.5 miles
and with smaller amounts um moving out
to up to 6.5 miles but they are very
very small amounts so we don't lay that
and that immediate radius around
altering them and hands
in terms of the activity and this was a
question you asked last time when we
came to scrutiny where did the activity
that was going children and minor
injuries go to
um during the stand down and the
proportion of patients being treated and
with insured during that time did
increase um not by the same number as
those that would have attended altering
minor injuries
on a on an annual basis but there was an
increase in in number of people
attending within shaw
that was supported by the staff being
redeployed from trafford
sorry from uptrend in general to um
within shaw and allowed a more flexible
staffing model which again the the team
from mft can take us through in more
detail
um we can't prove 100 that that's a
direct causation of it but the um
there's definitely a correlation in
terms of the number of patients but
there must have been some activity as
well that that was managed in different
ways perhaps going to pharmacies etc
so that takes us on to the slide in
terms of the short-term proposal so i'll
hand over to john who's going to take us
through that with sarah's support yeah
just just by way of introduction as as
you know from last time when we came um
we talked about the the opening of the
plans to reopen and the critical part of
that was ensuring that whatever we did
was safe
and that's um clearly been a central
part of the work that we've done to
assess what is the art of the possible
um in the short term so i know sarah and
jane can talk through perhaps some of
the detail of the proposal yeah thanks
john so in terms of what we've been
working towards obviously we have been
recruiting and training our nursing
staff to open this as soon as possible
given the number of nurses we've
currently got and the training that
we've invested in those staff
we're looking to open the uh the the
unit on a monday and tuesday which are
were the busiest days in altering him
from an eight o'clock to closing at four
o'clock so we're accepting patients a
little bit stopping patients a bit
sooner than that and then as we as as as
nurses come off the training program
the intention is to open the units four
days a week
based on our current recruitment and
retention strategy and that is as it
stands at the moment
we are looking it will be the middle of
next year before we were fully
operational in terms of a seven day
service
that's working on the assumption that
our staff are
are retained and that we don't have
significant loss or pressures
on the within shore site which is
obviously where we see the more urgent
cases it's also based on the premise
that as it stands at the moment we're
running a seven percent absence rate but
if we see waves and trends in terms of
covert and sickness levels
that that that is the risk that i would
have to put in the room in terms of the
risk to this unit but our intention is
that we would open it and that's what
james has been working with the nursing
staff towards
yes
yes i think um i suppose just to put
some context in terms of the workforce
we did lose half of the emergency nurse
practitioner workforce during the
pandemic they're a highly sought after
workforce and a number of them went into
primary care and and other areas so
we've worked extremely hard with our
nurse consultant to recruit um
we have been really successful um and
we've just had one lever who we we've
retained internally going into an
advanced clinical practitioner post so
we have done really well over the last
sort of six nine months in terms of
recruitment again we're out to
recruitment at the moment um and have
somebody were likely to to a point
um but as sarah said it's you know it's
depend very much dependent on that
workforce and the retention but we have
good professional development in place
and and staff are well supported so i
think it's stabilized really the
workforce now okay thank you jane
so we wanted to ask great need to
consider the the commitment to altering
him as a hospital and the stand-up of
altering minor injuries in the context
of the of the next section of slides so
it's really important that all the
people of trafford have access to high
quality urgent care which is offered in
a way that's really simple to navigate
and meets the needs of of the population
but we have to accept that we have to
work within the resources we have both
in terms of staff and also finances
and what we wanted to ask scrutiny was
for support for us to carry out a
system-wide urgent care review to both
understand the needs with the help of
our public health colleagues the access
to the various different points across
and the locality of trafford the demand
and the capacity needed to do that and
the best workforce models that we can do
with the with both in terms of
recruitment and financial flows and with
a commitment that we would do that as a
system by december um and the aim of
that would be that we would have a
future um strategic and operational
recommendations that could be made to
our locality board and nhs greater
manchester which we would then
co-produce with the population as well
so this wouldn't be just a standalone
strategic what we think about it we
would engage with the population around
it
make sure that we have um services that
are aligned to the needs of the
population
that access is simplified because we
have had the feedback it is actually
quite difficult to navigate the urgent
care system within trafford because of
the different um access points
and and prevent any variation or
duplication waste ensuring that the
services are um
in line with the national guidance which
is that we have a one-set offer which is
based around an urgent treatment center
which allows people to walk in but also
offers them a chance to have a slot that
and they know the time scales of when
they can attend
in that situation
so i'll take you through what we have in
terms of the needs assessment at the
moment and this this is just about
altering a minor injury so anything we
would do in the future would be much
broader and encompass the whole event
the whole of trafford but it's just to
give you the context about ultra minor
injuries
so the the long-term plan the nhs
long-term plan which is something that
we must implement um asks us to make
sure that we simplify access into urgent
care and that we work um to
stop the difference between walk-in
centers primary care etc and have access
that is easy to understand and badged
under urgent treatment centers and
emergency departments so that people
know what they're going to get whenever
they turn up at the door and it's a call
sorry a common offer
and
it's also about having um the the
confusion about the range of offers by
allowing different ways of entering into
the urgent care system either by walking
them being able to book being able to
phone and do something online or being
able to do something digital as well so
it's not one size fits all it's about
having a central way to be able to get
into the services and be able to
navigate it
and
if you look at the uh
we have at the moment so um
lots of areas as well as having our own
and our own care provision within
trafford so we have um
nad departments emergency department and
urgent and treatment centers in bostol
for royal mri and within shaw which are
all in our borders
as well as the private channels
urgent care access that we would have is
around extended access and strategies
etc
and
if you look at the wider determinants of
of health and
the the need in terms of altering them
as itself so the the south locality has
the largest proportion of residents over
64
within within trafford and and it has
the least deprived local state with um
four of at least five of the least
impressive awards being within the
borough noticing that there are a few
pockets of of deprivation as well in
areas that we'll be all familiar with
which is village world heath and and
some right in the middle of altering him
and in terms of the relationship and
between the the wedded determined
determinants in health we do have a
healthy population within without
altering them compared to everywhere
else
there is a small a small um variation in
terms of of child health outcomes but in
terms of the rest of the population it's
it's a more healthy
population you might be able to freeze
that better than me when it comes to
questions
um if you're a boy or girl that are born
in in south trafford you will live
longer than people born elsewhere within
trafford and also
although there's a higher proportion of
elderly people within um the south
they're more healthy compared to to
other areas within within the borough
if you then look at the the usage of um
altering a minor injuries compared to
the um
the deprivation within the um
within
the the area it shows you that the the
most of the um attendances come from
those
um people that are registered within the
um that the higher
higher less deprivation area
um and unless access from where there's
where there's deprivation they're going
elsewhere within within the system
and the next slide shows that in in
better detail
um shows that um in terms of those
attending um altering a minor injuries
which
the less deprived is the pink colors and
and the blue is more deprived the
highest um population attending ultra
minor injuries is from the less deprived
population um and and that's quite a
significant um number of of people
attending from there as well
as i say i present it to you today
basically just the information about
altering around your minor injuries our
proposal is that we would look at the
whole system and and
all the areas within trafford and the
urgent care needs as well and map the
provision to make sure that whatever we
stand up and however we have the access
to urgent care that actually fits the
needs of the population there um
and that it meets in line with the
national guidance that we need to work
towards as well so
um just in summary it's it's for
scrutiny's questioning and consideration
about the proposal that has been made by
mft and also um how that sits within the
proposal as well for us to carry out
this urgent care review in that timely
manner and bring that back through
scrutiny to be able to make decisions
about how we best meet the needs of the
population moving forward
and i'll stop there and if i've missed
anything please come in helen will be
able to answer some more questions about
the slides where um i might have got a
bit stuck in the technical detail but
i'll stop there
okay thank you very much for that
does anybody have any
points to make
right
let's start with
yourself
um i didn't get a chance to introduce
myself earlier um being slightly delayed
i'm councillor jane brophy and i
represent timpani ward
in um
trafford i also just need to perhaps
just mention if it's probably already on
the minutes but i work for mft at wooden
shore hospital so i'm just as a
formality
making sure that's in the notes
somewhere and so my question is um thank
you for the presentation
um
very interesting to have the update um
good that there is a plan to sort of
reopen services at altering a minor
injuries unit
and and
also noting the long-term plans that
you've mentioned and the population
and my question is in terms of the point
made about navigating urgent care in
trafford
i do wonder whether people outside of
altering are actually aware of if it
the the with the opening that's planning
and whatever the long term future might
be
what publicity and what communication do
we have to make people aware of what
services are there because i think some
of the lack of
perhaps attendance and the very narrow
areas you've outlined who have used the
service previously it might just be
knowledge of what the services are there
and i'm wondering as part of this plan
that you've presented
what are the plans to communicate that
to the wider population
so we at council brophy we've got a full
communications plan um that would be
briefed out to stakeholders it wouldn't
just be um just about altering a minor
injury standing back up it would be
coached in the urgent treatment center
access how we're encouraging people to
be able to use the the t-pass service
which will um uh stream and direct them
to um appropriate services for um their
needs as well
so there's a full stakeholder plan
i think
it's about being clear as well with the
the two days a week moving to the four
days a week as well we will have to
support that through the central kind of
telephone service as well to be able to
ensure that people don't turn up
whenever it's not open etc but yes it's
about um we we will continuously put
that message out
council leicester
um the else going to answer then part of
the question sorry i just saw your light
come on
no
it's okay thanks naomi it's just to say
that as part of mft we would support as
well in terms of our social media in
terms of but again that would be couched
in the one-on-one offer it wouldn't just
be about altering them it would be how
to access services
[Music]
thank you i'm councillor leicester um i
was representing hail central but i've
actually i wanted to see if i understood
something correctly because in one of
the slides you showed the attendance by
areas of deprivation both altering them
injury minor injuries union and other
areas and it appeared from my
understanding was that the lowest
attendance at all at any you at any site
was in the less deprived sorry in the
more deprived areas i'm guessing the
right way around
um
so but when you look at the map
obviously you've got partington uh which
is one of the one of the more deprived
areas within the borough and i think it
ties in actually with what councilor
brophy was just saying about advertising
that if you've got people in those areas
that are tending not to present fully
not just altering them but at other
areas as well but it's surely there's
some work to be done there to actually
encourage the people that should be
presenting
at the units to get the support that
they actually need and so it ties in
with the advertising but more perhaps
more specifically to a specific area
i think that's that's the point we're
making about trying to understand the
total needs of the population because
we've we've just concentrated in that
kind of area around altering them and
when we would be looking at the wider
review it would be understanding the
needs within partington and also then
the transport issues etc and how people
could travel and i think it's important
to look at that in its entirety and then
translate that into how we communicate
with people as well helen i don't know
whether you want to add something yeah
thanks councillor just to agree with
what you've said really and there's
there's a wealth of evidence around
access to health care and how different
growth
cohorts do that particularly in their
more deprived areas are less likely to
seek
health support so that is something we
need to look at at a population level as
well as part of this review
okay councilor hartley
uh thank you chair and thank you for the
report and the in particular the data
that that's uh included which i think is
really useful in terms of
uh seeing how the minor injuries unit is
used or was used i think
uh like like councillor browfing council
lester i think
there's a sort of sense that it might be
a missed opportunity here and that um
for a lot of people in south trafford
you know altering them for minor ranges
would be quite accessible um
and i also i can't remember if
one of you raised this but i think
i have some concerns about stepping up
to two days a week and then four days a
week because you know you fall over and
you think you're broken your arm then
you're not going to remember whether
it's open on a monday or tuesday um so i
think yeah in terms of information that
that is key and you know by phone as
well as um online for those that don't
have internet access
um
the the question i had was around um
waiting times so
i i mean i fully appreciate what's in
the report and the data does show that
it's quite a tight-knit area around
altering them that that tend to use it
but i think one of the reasons they do
use it and i think this is in the report
is that
they get they get seen quickly um and
and i've been told from in the past i'll
have in sale but i've been talking in
the past and i've known that i have been
seen quickly had an x-ray and been seen
quickly and
um i suspect a lot more quickly than it
than it would insure a knee and i think
i think bear in is maybe
um the worry for trafford residents who
might who might use altering them uh or
might have used it in the past and i
think i raised this last time around
is there data around a comparison in
wait times for
people attending with insurance compared
to the minor injuries unit when it was
fully operational and i think the answer
was around
you could make inquiries with
the powell's team about that
um and and there may be complaints there
about delays with the pals team but
not everyone goes to the pulse team and
makes and makes complaints and
so i think in a way i'm repeating the
question but i think
with with some
uh skepticism may because i i would have
thought that data would be available
because when you book in even a even if
you're
feeling very unwell you provide all your
details so you've got the postcodes of
everyone attending and you could you
could match that to those people in
altering them hail
um simply you might otherwise have
attended altering them so
i i you know i think
appreciating what's in the report i
think uh and maybe you can't answer it
now but it may be something as part of
the review
those
12 13 000 people who would use ultringum
um
i think what they would want to know is
is the service
better or is it worse that we're unsure
and my suspicion is that it's worse
because you hear horror stories around
the wait times at weather and chore
and so i think that's the challenge so i
don't know if you can give any
information on that or whether that
could be picked up as part of the review
i think sarah and i could probably
answer this between us so i i think on
paper it would be clear to say that you
you would have shorter waiting times
going to trafford general than you would
have um with in within within shaw
but it's about looking at the needs of
the population compared to that as well
so it's a really fine balance isn't it
um so have we got a service that's
really easily accessed for a small niche
of of people with an alternative and
actually wider needs where we need to
put a service elsewhere and i think
that's what we're trying to understand
within within the review and i think
you're absolutely right what you
wouldn't want to do was then replace
anything or keep anything with it with a
poorer access or para-time scales so
it's about matching them the service
offered to the needs as well
i would suggest if we did a needs
assessment of altering them the needs
for altering them would be
wider than just broken arms and broken
legs and actually it's about having easy
access to services in emergencies other
than those as well so i think there's
there's an important bit to do in terms
of yes we need to make sure it's easy
access but it needs to meet the the
needs as well and sarah will probably be
able to kind of answer the detail about
the um the current weights etc but the
plan would be that we we make
everything accessible to the best we
possibly can do with the workforce that
we have and the finances we have
sorry in helen
and just to speculate as well as i
imagine that the presentations that a e
will be very different than the
presentations that uh the minor injuries
so that will have an impact on waiting
time there as well
sarah it might be useful to talk about
the streaming and stuff as well we've
got it with insurer
yeah thanks naomi so absolutely in terms
of do i doubt that the waiting times
were shorter altering them than they
would be at with insure
they were absolutely would be but the
case mix is completely different and
actually that's why the staff were moved
in the first place in terms of that need
and that demand
to to to treat the most sickest patients
if you like in terms of that that staff
may have
i think if you're looking at with
insurer one of the things we're trying
to do what we are doing is streaming
from the front door to look at
alternatives in instead of ed
and that is part of the work that i
don't doubt you would do in terms of
this review looking at what options are
available for the service and the
patient need so it's it's
the answer to the question is absolutely
the waiting times will be shorter
altering them but actually
naomi's point is much more valid in
terms of what are the needs of the
population in its totality
and
so it said councillor taylor next
thank you chair councillor sophie taylor
councillor for clifford ward
um i think this just again builds on the
previous questions and i think the last
point that you made naomi that
this almost suggests that we have
possibly a very niche service for a very
small
uh sector of the population who probably
the least deprived and that i think i'm
just glad to hear that this wider review
is going to be undertaken really because
almost sort of suggests or begs the
question is this service actually needed
you know i know you're talking about re
rebuilding it and reopening it again but
it almost suggests that it's
it's possibly not the best use of
resources really so i'm just really glad
that you're having this wider um borough
wide review i mean i represent clifford
ward which is a
is the opposite end of the scale in
terms of of need and probably has
much lower levels of service and access
really you know it just um asks begs the
question is this service best placed in
the borough i know it's a wonderful
facility but is it actually really
serving the people who need it the most
that's my point thank you
i suppose that the response to that is
that would be the purpose of the review
so you know the information we provided
tonight has been very nice just around
altering them we need to look at this in
the wider sense and it's been very niche
in terms of ad and
urgent treatment centers whereas
actually we've got our gp colleagues who
have now just started to do extend to
ours etc and then the the point that was
made as well it if we could downstream
things and actually proactively prevent
illnesses in emergencies and we can't
prevent people well you can prevent
people falling over but you can't all
with the time can you but you can
prevent um illnesses as well so that's
one of the other focuses but it's not to
kind of predict any conclusion at the
end of a review it's to it's to do that
properly
i mean i think obviously it was coving
that prompted these changes but actually
it's widened it to
a broader debate hasn't it about what's
actually really needed in the bureau so
it is very welcome and we
would look forward to ongoing updates
and uh engagement in that discussion so
thank you
council mrs young
patricia young and i'm from hail central
ward
i seem to have been involved as i have
been with scrutiny for
a considerable number of years now
i think going right back to when i was
first made a council in 2004
and i have been asking continually for
all of that time
trying to campaign for services
to come into waltringham general
hospital
we've been
asking i i remember sitting on scrutiny
something like about 15 years ago and
trying to persuade scrut trying to
persuade the then um minor injuries unit
which was called something else at the
time to stay open it was then opened it
was open i remember from nine to five
and we eventually managed to persuade
the unit to stay open till midnight
and it was used and it was used well
and it was used by people not only in
the old genome area but also the people
around
at the moment it's even easier now
to get to waltingham general hospital
than it used to be before the metro was
built when
i we were originally arguing about
trying to keep the hospital
because people now from the sale
anywhere along the line where they can
get to the metro it's much easier for
them to get to waltringham than it is to
get to within shaw or to get to trafford
general
it you know you have to and i think if
people know that the service is there
and that they can go to it and that they
can use it then they will use it i mean
there was a time when the
phlebotomy services when the early
closed and again i'm going back about 15
years
and that was because they had
people used to turn up and
take a ticket to use and there was
at the time phlebotomy services came
from a very small room almost in the
basement of the hospital i don't know if
there's anyone in this room who
remembers it it was a little tiny room
and there were a couple of seats on one
side of the room and you got in there
you had to wave with the nurse and get
on here you know
put my name down and eventually you were
seen
and
they put the
the system changed and you have to
telephone to get an appointment and if
you tried to telephone the phones either
weren't answered or you were given an
appointment for two weeks later or
something and so people stopped going
there
and so
they were the it was the
question had been asked should it be
closed and we made the pointed scrutiny
that make it easier for people to access
and they'll go there and actually the
system was then changed we were listened
to and the services were moved to the
first floor of the hospital and you
could get there get a ticket get your
blood test and be out again within an
hour
and within a few months the system that
was virtually going to close because
hardly anyone was going was dealing with
hundreds of people
a week because people the word went
round that the system is there the
service is there you can go to it
and so you did so the point i'm rambling
on about this
is that
if the
minor injuries unit could open again or
could we could aim at opening it again
eventually as a daily unit not four days
a week or two days a week but hopefully
seven days a week it may be pie in the
sky but i think it's what should be
aimed at and for longer than eight to
four because you know we've got school
children very often if a child comes
into an accident on a school playground
and we have a huge number of schools in
the ortingham area it's much easier for
the school staff to take the children in
into hospital they can be in and back
almost before the school day is over so
for the sheer convenience for everybody
having the hospital there and it isn't
something that should be looked at as
being for the people of all genome i
always see it as something that should
be there to serve the people in general
to the whole of the south of trafford
because if if there's a a good system
and a good unit somewhere somewhere
people will use it there's no getting
away from that so i'm sorry to ramble on
about this a little bit but honestly i
have been campaigning on this
for i should think well over the past 20
of years since i even even before i
became a counselor when we've been faced
time and again
at times with with having the hospital
closed completely i'm not sure for what
has reopened off the code if but have
the radiology services opened again
because that was that is again what is
so good
with the minor injuries unit is having
the radiology unit by it
because if somebody goes in with a
suspected break it could be checked
anyway i'm sorry to go ramble on it's
fine because i think in a way we we
agree with you it's about having the
services for the people of trafford that
are accessible to them and i think it's
we have to get that balance between the
need in terms of of how people are using
it and the needs of the population but
also our ability our cost effectiveness
and our ability to staff it as well so
the proposal around the um we're not
proposing to close altring and we're
proposing to do exactly what you've just
said and look at what are the needs of
the population where will people travel
from what will they use and how can we
staff it what finances have we got and
actually what can we then do and co and
design that with the population and i
think it might be useful if if sarah and
g and kind of maybe go through the
services aren't altering him at the
moment because i think there's a bit of
a perception that it's it's an empty
building and and
and it isn't and it's something that
we're all committed to ensuring that
other services are provided out of
altering him i think he had a bit of a
list before didn't you say that you were
going to go through i think this will be
a double act in in terms of this from a
memory perspective but yes i mean we
have obviously physio radiology services
we have dialysis services there there's
cardiology clinics there's ophthalmology
clinics ent clinics that and that was
just the top of our head gene i don't
know if you can remember no anymore is
that no that's the full list yes but in
terms of certainly in terms of the eye
hospital services you know they have a
huge amount of activity that goes
through those clinics um and also for
renal dialysis you know serves the whole
um area for for renal patients so you
know from from those services it is
really well used at hospital
[Music]
okay and we're taking that as a big
commitment to
that
building going forward by the nhs okay
thank you
i'm going to bring in council coggins
now
she's an altering award council is not
member of the committee but
um
this
hospital is is in her ward
thank you chair for uh letting me speak
because i'm not on the committee um
i i you've just carried covered some of
my one of my questions there and to
clarify really for people watching at
home that this isn't about the whole
hospital only about the minor injuries
unit because i think there is a lot of
confusion um out there
and
and i think we've had some interesting
discussion about
the relative lack of use
whether it's caused by an actual lack of
demand or a lack of knowledge and
and i guess that's part of what this
analysis needs to look at whether it's
just so people don't know where to go
um but i was interested in maybe just
discussing some of the deeper issues
behind this because obviously things
have changed um and i think from the
discussions i think i've helpfully had
with some of you before
there
was
two
issues there was both an increase in
demand for urgent care of different
types and also a reduced supply of staff
um and i suppose
the question is how we can um
you know look at those deeper issues as
well because i realize that those of you
in the nhs are forced to make do with
the resources you have available um but
those of us who are here on the council
can actually you know i suppose
ask for for for more in a sense that you
know we don't have to buy into this
austerity narrative that we either have
a hospital the service people in
ultraham or one the service say cancer
taylor's residence in old trafford or
the people in parkington who seem to be
under resourced at the moment
and i suppose are the things that can be
done now to improve the situation in a
few years time do we need
much more training of nurse
practitioners is it mostly a funding
problem is it mostly a training problem
and
and of course we also need to keep doing
all the things that will reduce demand
and making those lifestyle changes
um and so on so yeah interested in what
we can do going forward to both increase
the supply of staff
reduce the demand and actually give us a
healthier happier population thanks
again i think we'll probably do a bit of
a double act on that so i completely
agree with you it's about supporting
people to live long and healthy lives
wife's also having really good access to
emerging emergency care because we will
always need that and and and perhaps
through chair we could we can agree for
a future agenda and to start to talk
about the anticipatory care work and the
population health work that we're
starting to work on as well
and in terms of
the workforce and i think jane and sarah
be more qualified to answer than me but
i think
after the initial needs review i think
whatever we do we'll have to have a
workforce plan in terms of that and
that's something we need to look across
not just mft's responsibility but maybe
other other trusts across gm but also in
the locality as well and working with
our social care colleagues because
workforce is a rate limiting factor for
a lot of things at the moment um it
tends not to be um that finance driven
in terms of um we can't afford the staff
it's that we can't get the staff but
i'll hand over to gm because you're
you're the one that recruits them also
thank you um so in terms of nurse
practitioners just to put it into
context a bit so they tend to be um from
a an accident emergency background
um
but they need to be experienced you know
at all trinium they are working
autonomously so they need to be able to
assess patients appropriately and and
manage them um and discharge them so
um in order to train an emergency nurse
practitioner it's um they spend well but
it's a year-long university course um
not not full-time but there are a number
of modules that they complete
and then really in order to work ultrium
they need at least another six nine
months elsewhere to develop those skills
and be able to work competently
um and autonomously within that
environment and so you can see it you
know it's not a quick fix to get an
emergency nurse practitioner we did have
a really stable workforce as i explained
earlier and i think covid just brought
some instability you know we're hoping
we've managed to stabilize again um but
they are very sought after and so for us
in terms of the retention of that
workforce we do have a nurse consultant
who's highly skilled in in management of
this patient group and she offers you
know continual professional development
for this workforce
um so
you know it we are well we've been out
to advert for the last 18 months and
have slowly built that workforce back up
again
so again it's not it's not about finance
this is about the resource and being
able to attract those individuals and
keep them
and it is a relatively small workforce
isn't it so it is a niche market in
terms of actually recruiting to this so
you can it can fluctuate significantly
okay thank you councillor acton
sorry i just wanted to comment on about
the preventions um elements so
i suppose it's it's more than the
management of the ultranam um minor
injuries issues isn't it this is about
demand at a e and supporting um
kind of
improved self-management of people who
do have a long a chronic long-term
condition and also reducing the
prevalence of um conditions such as copd
um
and all the other conditions which your
colleagues will see day in day out
presenting to a e so as a public health
team we're working in the locality with
our partners and at gm and at regional
to really think about how we reduce
smoking how we improve healthy weight
and also physical activity so that's
some really ongoing work that will feed
into this needs assessment as well
because it all needs to fit around the
population health approach to reducing
demand on our services
okay council acton
thank you
uh i'm david atten councillor for ghost
hill ward um
yeah
i'm quite pleased that you you've
acknowledged that this
manor injury unit will
survive um
obviously it is in need of some kind of
long-term review and i think that's
probably accepted by
most of us
um
but
but i think what needs to be done and
what seems to be
um you know you're referring to it a
complete redesign
of the service because i think it would
be a shame to lose that service it's the
only one
that we have i think in in trafford um
and
what what it
can do and what it should do and
probably what is
doing less
of
is relieving the pressures
on a e in in
the other hospitals
and and that is a good thing and and one
that we should be
really looking at so that people have a
better better offer in terms of a e
than they have at this moment in time
so
i i would like to see you know how how
you would
redesign that in a way that um will
i think
create a hospital
that counselor young said
that belongs to the whole of trafford
and and that people will be glad to
actually go there and recognize it and i
think it goes back to other speakers
about
you know how we communicate all of that
because that communication is really
important so that they know what that
offer is
so i think you know
for me
and i think you know hopefully the
scrutiny committee you know we could
work with you in terms of uh looking at
that long-term review
um
to
do the best that we can for a redesign
to make it
something that um
you know that will be relevant to the
whole of trafford and that will relieve
the pressures on on other hospitals
that's a really helpful offer and
actually our our plan if we get support
tonight is that we we pull our resources
together as different parts of the nhs
and also working with social care
colleagues to our public health story
to make sure we do
exactly what you articulate
thank you right we're coming out on to
the second lap now so it's councillor
brophy
okay so my second question kind of
pulling together all the points that
have been made by other people
and i think we're looking at the
short-term plan here which is like a
two-day model
and then a four-day model
and then the long-term plan i just want
to
make some points about joining those two
stages together because
one of the concerns i have about the
short-term plan where you've opened it
for a couple of days a week and then
you're probably sort of collecting data
in terms of how well it's used
is that might not really indicate how
people would use it where it's an
established and well-known service
so
in terms of the things pulling out the
other points that people have made to
make sure these things are considered
looking at david atkinson's point there
about
people in altingham who use the minor
injuries service there
how many of them would otherwise be
going to within shaw for the problem or
going to trafford for the problem
because having that service and altering
will mean the services at trafford and
with insurer are less pressured
and and also
thinking outside the box because i'm
aware that ultringham is a
demographically an area with left
decoration
but i don't think that should be
kind of the whole rationale for how this
model is looked at although i do
completely get the point that
and deprive service areas do need more
services just because
people there have have more health
problems so i
and the prevention side of it as well i
completely get the reasons why deprived
areas need more services but it's
thinking about wider so we've talked
about parsington
and it's well known that transport links
departing to the particularly bad so it
might be
that thinking outside the box that if we
and with insurer as well within sure
most of temple is only sort of five or
ten minutes away from within shaw
um
and so really whilst you look at that
area of travel being sort of on average
about 1.5 miles
that if the transport links into
altering enable people in partington to
get from
there into ultranumb or from within
shore into ultranumb
that would mean that the service could
be accessible to a much bigger
population group because
otherwise and and i suspect this is more
what people are used to as well and
building on councillor young's points as
well historically i've been around on
this committee quite a while and
altering hospital has always been sort
of part of the discussion here
and that's why my starting point was
about the communications because i think
that
once you've got those workforce issues
solved it just sounds like you're kind
of working towards a solution there the
staff are being trained
um but i'd hate to think that it was
open for two days and then four days but
the data said nobody used it and
therefore
it doesn't have a long-term future
because i think
in terms of the way the data collect is
collected i'd like to see there are more
um
wider picture looked at in terms of the
transport links from outside auction and
where it is more deprived within shaw
and partington
and it's also thinking of the long-term
population in ultron as well
um it was mentioned there's over 65s
again that's a growing population area
that group of people need more hospital
care not be necessarily because they're
deprived of just getting older
people in that age bracket tend not to
have their own transport anymore tend to
rely on
and buses and
other way taxis etc or family members
and also the ultrim demographics it is
growing in population so if you've got
got a lot more families with young
children in particular parts of watching
them so
as part of that exercise looking at the
long term can i ask that these factors
are considered and i'll just summarize
what they are looking at the
the number of over 65s who might use the
services more the growing population of
children and families
the access
to those services for people from the
nearby deprived areas partington and
within sure and other deprived areas
also within
ultron itself those deprived areas so i
just think with a bigger scope to that
long-term plan
the vision that we've all got that
councilor young has outlined and we've
all been working towards on this
committee over over decades
that could happen if we just had a sort
of wider scope to looking at that
long-term plan
so when we do a health needs assessment
we would look at all those factors but
particularly looking at um projections
within the population and we are aware
that there are certain pockets where
there is an increase in profile so for
some areas we have an increase in our
zero to fives but in others it'll be the
older and that would be what we would
take into account across the whole of
trafford when we're looking at that we'd
also look at our protective populations
as well so disability
age uh and gender but and that kind of
leads to that really important thing
about who then is attending so this is
telling us numbers but we don't know if
that's men or women or people with a
disability or um particular cohorts
within our communities of interest and
that's really important in terms of
addressing health inequality that we are
aware of that
and and then i think the big question of
a health needs assessment is going out
to our communities and asking
where they access their health and why
so you may have it may be that they
don't know about altering them but it
may be that you go to partington and go
actually uh we don't go to alternate
because
you know it takes me this amount of time
or i can't leave my children or or you
know i'd go to the pharmacy the next day
so it's really important that all the
data it's not just numbers it's not just
rates but it's it's that building that
picture from the bottom
up and that's what we would do with a
health needs assessment for this and i
think also we would build in an element
of a health equity audit so it's looking
at who's accessing what services and
what groups aren't accessing services
and why
so it would be a big piece of work but
there's a huge amount of evidence
available already that we would be able
to tap into it's just pulling it all
together i think and i think just to
give the assurance we wouldn't be
looking at the utilization why it's a
different model it's it's about engaging
with the population etc and then i think
the other thing that the need to then
would be couched within the offers
remember and of course that alternative
minor injuries just looks after broken
legs and arms etc and actually the needs
of the population might be wider than
that
dan did you want to come in on this
point
um no it's it's a wider point on behalf
of social care really chair so i'll wait
if you want to okay there's a couple
more on my list and then so um councilor
leicester
thank you chair i think you actually
just allude i've got two questions
actually but one i think you just
alluded to because i was about to ask
about why the unit is only minor
injuries and not minor illnesses as well
so i don't know if there's a specific
reason for that given there are clinical
medical services within the hospital so
because i didn't know that part of it
was to do with medical backup
um
i think it's historic it probably has
got to do with the independence of the
nurses i'm just seeing my colleagues
node and i think it's really important
that we look at the services based on on
the on the need rather than being wedded
to the model that the other bit just
alluding back to what i said at the
start as well nhs guidance now is asking
us to move away from standalone minor
minor injuries units and actually
ensuring that they have um a wider
intake and being able to to manage a
wider
and a wider need of the population
really to be honest and again we need to
fit that into where can we get the
workforce where can we get the the
estate and the finance as well so we're
committing to a huge piece of work here
to do it but i think it's really
important that we do
because the second part of my question
actually related to workforce and i say
this is a physiotherapist we keep
talking about advanced nurse
practitioners are you using other
professionals as well as
other advanced practitioners
yes or working to train them up
so um within the wooden shore um urgent
treatment centre we do have a physio
practitioner
and so yes we we've looked at other
workforce models as well
okay
alex did you want to come in
not only you know brief um
just asking about your review and um
whether you do your data sets across
ward boundaries and whether you're doing
any work that's looking at the new ward
boundaries that will come in from next
year
[Music]
measuring sorry yes we would would use
all the new data that comes through
and alex as well we may have to look
across trafford boundaries as well and
stockport and manchester as well because
we do have populations that access in
different ways as well
okay councillor hartley
thank you chad i think dave um council
acton covered um
covered my point uh in a way but i just
wanted to develop it a bit more so i
think
i i think what what i'd like to review
to do is to is to not lose sight of the
fact that i think altering them could be
an opportunity so i appreciate it might
be a
almost a luxurious service to the people
that don't live in that area but it but
it could represent a model that i think
as cancer attend said
could relieve pressure on on any
departments you know as a as a local hub
for minor injuries minor illnesses
um some diagnostics because i suspect of
you if you spoke to a resident in old
trafford who thought they'd broken their
arm and said you can go to the wedding
show and wait for six hours or you can
go to altering him and be seen within an
hour or two they definitely got to alter
him so a lot of it is about
knowing what services
are there and
i appreciate we can't turn the clock
back we're not going to have a district
general hospital in altering them you
know that model of health care has
has gone but i do think um
and actually and the answer to my last
question about the wait times
i think the answers were around yes wait
times are longer with ensure because of
the mix of cases and and therein
probably is the problem i suspect that
if you send people with minor injuries
to a e along with suspected heart
attacks
people coming through dd you're into
that big mix of triage by a nurse triage
by a doctor waiting to get an x-ray when
there's been a road accident or whatever
so
i suppose the opportunity i think is
that if you if you budget correctly and
people know it's there then it's a
self-selecting service and you relieve
some of that pressure um
i don't particularly like urgent
treatment centers that doesn't say a lot
to me i suppose minor injuries
i think as you said it does what it says
on the tin so i think i think there is
an element of self-selection there so
sorry it's not necessarily a question
that needs answering but i i just wanted
to sort of encourage that really
you know in line with what ken
schloratson said thank
thanks i think we just want to talk a
little bit about how we stream at the
front door though in terms of the
pathways that we have available on the
wooden shore site so ginger yeah so
um within short eight to eight currently
at the moment we have an experienced
nurse who is at the front of the um
entrance to edie
and they stream patients
we do have an urgent treatment center so
anybody um with a minor injury or
illness because we have primary care
support as well will be streamed to to
the utc to be seen so it's very
difficult you know if you present to ed
to actually
um you know that we've got headlines
about long wait but actually if you come
with that defined presentation actually
you wait a relatively short period of
time and just to back that up and what
it's in excess of 80 of those patients
go through in less than four hours and
some of them significant most of them
significantly less than that time
okay
and you wanted to come in thank you and
it was just sort of um feeding back some
thoughts and issues from social care
obviously we're supporting
a smaller group of people but usually
the most some of the most vulnerable
people within our society
i'm quite concerned about two days being
quite confusing for people so i'm glad
that the committee has picked up on that
issue
um
people when they're unwell and
particularly our vulnerable populations
will not have access to to work out
where to go
and you'll get more ambulance calls i
think so that's just a risk issue and i
would i was going to
ask whether the councillors would be
supportive of future proofing some of
this by linking it to the cost of living
work that we're doing across the council
which many councils will know about
because for a lot of our deprived areas
travel costs were are going to be a real
issue you are going to be prioritizing
food and heating and paying your rent
rather than travel to hospitals so i
think we will see a decline in access to
health care quite significantly over the
coming
years and i i just think having that
connection will really help this review
um and i'm sure i'm looking at
jane winter is a very very difficult
time for health and social care so
timing of changes and thinking about
things carefully so that we don't
destabilize we've done a lot of work
around maximizing home care provision on
our care homes supported alongside our
local care organization and mft really
collaborating and we have done very very
well over the summer um to make sure
that we've got people in the right place
so the timing of what anything any
changes is really important not to
destabilize that support to get people
home and keep people at home as quickly
as we can
thank you
okay thank you i want to just ask
judy collins would you like to
comment judy's a
an alternative community campaigner and
uh
well-known feature and i know she's
campaigned about aspects of ultram
hospital before now
[Music]
um thanks very much i think all the
officers here know who i am
um
the community in altringham fought very
hard to get this hospital built
um
we've had meetings with
mft
with our world councillors graham brady
has been really really helpful
um
the advanced nurse practitioners is
something that
was a problem
decades ago before the new hospital was
built
it's a bit like cams
that
it's not just a problem that's arisen
now so i'm really glad that it's been
taken seriously
um nobody so far has mentioned
ultringham's health and well-being
center
this was sold to us by the ccg
as a holistic center working closely
with ultringham hospital
and
being not just about clinics and gps but
there would be a library where you could
walk through to the rest of the building
none of this has happened
we feel that we have two really really
good resources in the town center and
neither of them are being fully used
so i think it would be a really really
good thing
to to have a review
um
minor injuries has always been the um
the thing that kept altering him
hospital going as i'm sure councillor
young will agree
um
and
i'm not sure that minor injury is really
linked to deprivation
um i'm doing a lot of work with the
combined authority from the aging well
point of view
i'm sitting on quite a lot of panels and
i know
uh about deprivation across the greater
manchester area
um and i think leveling up means that
trafford's got to try and be more
together and not think oh the south's
full of footballers and the north is
really deprived
because i don't think that that's
necessarily so
and i think
[Music]
that
really say bowdoin doesn't have a gp
surgery so
all the bowdoin residents have to come
into altering them or to hell barnes
so
it would be really good wouldn't it if
gps weren't bothered and i know st
john's in health and well-being center
is doing an excellent job with social
prescribing but building is mostly empty
and and and hasn't delivered
what was promised
um i
very much doubt that there's very much
connection between the two buildings at
all and that that really is a shame
um
as i say we've had meetings with mft and
with the ccg as well but we never get
any follow-ups um which is a shame
because you know we're volunteers we
really care
um
and
i think after we took
trafford healthcare trust as was then to
a successful judicial review
um the late pap morris and i were
approached
from all over the country by people
saying we have problems
how can we solve them
and um
i think i think that's right that
um
[Music]
we
we got the hospital because we fought
for it
and
it's it's it's really sad that
it's not fulfilling its potential and i
i quite agree that we we need to look at
things and see how they work i do know
that during
the periods that minor injuries has been
opened that within shaw was shipping
patients out to altering them in taxes
to stop the long waiting list there and
i'm really really pleased that the
situation's
improved
but i'm very very concerned about this
two days a week because as i say we were
approached from hospitals and
communities all over the country
and if we look at say northwich and
congleton on our doorsteps
if there's uncertainty about minor
injuries or services people just won't
go
so if we
if the two days a week and then the four
days a week in january starts have we
gotten a guarantee that
if there is then a shortage of staff
that there will be unforecast closures
had that i can see why that would happen
and i think councillor brophy is quite
right in raising the transport issues i
mean we we've been through this again
over decades that it is almost
impossible to get to trafford general
from the south of the borough
they're taking patients from cheshire
east i do know
and say from knutsford in a car
to trafford general is taking over an
hour
for very very minor procedures
um i think what's happening now is that
patients are being offered quite
far away you know
to get better to get better health care
and this will obviously happen with
healthier together stage two
um so i think transport is really really
important
uh we know that within shaw was supposed
to get the tram and then didn't
and i know
when felicity goody was chair she tried
to get a loop
um but if anybody's trying to get to
trafford general from the south of the
borough by public transport
it's not a happy experience
thank you very much chair okay
check it out
you make a really valid point today
about making sure that we get the voice
of the population and any review that we
do and the voice across all all of the
neighborhoods as well i think it's
really important
and and again just to reinforce that
transport is is is part of what we need
to look at as well and the access for
people into it
[Music]
well thank you i'm going to bring this
item to a close now i think
we've we've had a good um
exchange of information
it's always good i think to to have
so much input from from counsellors
um and i think it
is a good way of illustrating to the
officers about the the concern of a
particular issue
um
so we've looked at the big picture um
it's been very good it's been very
encouraging
i just want to close by close by
focusing back on ultrium minor injuries
unit like many of the speakers i share
the concern about the
um
the method of reopening the two days a
week then four days a week the
lesser number of hours
um
it used to be 76 hours a week
it's going to start at 16 hours a week
then move to 32 hours a week
you hope to hit
76 hours a week
by the middle of next year
what i would urge is is that
um that every pressure is put on to to
bring those dates forward
so um
you've got a
um
the the two day is imminent
uh the four days from january
maybe that could be brought forward
uh i would hope that the seven days full
hours service
um
could be
arrived at
before june july time
and i would urge all of those involved
to make that their target for it
to be as soon as possible
uh rather than mid
2023 um but thank you everybody for your
input into that i think it's been um
very helpful i think it shows it was
uh right to bring the matter to um this
committee
and
i feel that um
there's a a lot of good information has
been exchanged as a result of that so
thank you everybody on that one
chair could i just say that the next
steps we're taking this to our locality
board next week
next tuesday and we'll we'll update the
presentation on the views that have come
through from from scrutiny as well and
make sure that any proposals we have for
needs assessments in the longer term
plan are shaped based on that as well as
well as the short-term plan
thank you and thank you to colleagues
from mft who i'm sure have had a very
long day being operational you're going
to leave us now
[Music]
my thanks to you as well for for your
attendance tonight and your and your
input into it so it's been very good
so we're moving on to item six which is
dental services and receive a report
from the
head of primary care for greater
manchester nhs greater manchester
indicated care
that's not me that's it that's been so
just just explain
what was the ccg doesn't commission
dental services it's done by nhsa so ben
squires is here with some other members
of the team to be able to take you
through the questions that you've asked
for
thank you very much for explaining that
naomi and thank you very much chair and
committee for the opportunity to
discuss dentistry here this evening
as naming explained a dentistry here has
been commissioned since 2013 by nhs
england nationally it's subject to
national regulations and that and the
national contract um but with the most
recent changes in in the nhs um
nhs great manchester as the integrated
care board has taken delegated authority
to be able to commission
dental services locally although still
subject to those national regulations
and contracts so here so
my team is part of nhs greater
manchester hold responsibility around
the commissioning and contracting of
dentistry which includes not just
primary care dentistry but specialists
come here dentistry in the community and
in the hospitals as well
in trafford we have 39
36 dental practices
if we started with a blank piece of
paper we made a voice to distribute them
slightly differently but we we have what
we have um
but also we here in here primary care we
have four orthodontic practices we have
a urgent dental care services as well um
and also in the community we have the
provision of specialist services
delivered by my colleagues from
bridgewater
community healthcare foundation trust
and i have this evening with me but i
have barry hutton and
hannah cook who are from that team and
will be able to um to
respond to any questions that are
relevant to them later on i'm also
pleased to say that i have vijay agarwal
with me from the trafford local dental
committee um
the committee representing the local
practices to be able to also respond to
any questions that the committee
committee has
for her
direct delivery of her of dentistry the
experience of practices and the
challenges that her that the services
are facing so it airs so
i recognize that the value of this
evening
is based in her questions and answers
and discussion
and i hope that committee members have
had the opportunity to read through the
report that was provided i will if
it's okay just
look to highlight certain sections of
the report rather than go through it up
verbatim and hopefully allow
sufficient time for a good discussion
and for following that
so clearly dentistry nationally as well
as locally is significantly challenged
i'm not here to try and pretend that any
other whites um if the sad events of
last thursday hadn't had taken place it
was uh expected that there was going to
be a documentary on television on
thursday evening presenting the national
challenges and that didn't go ahead but
i expect it to happen um at some point
in the future and that reflects that
actually nationally um that there's
significant access challenges for
dentistry and als also challenges around
oral health
a lot of that
is um here is the outcome of the
experience of the pandemic prior to
covid we had a relatively stable
position of nhs dentistry across the
greater manchester and within trafford
um it wasn't fantastic
but we didn't have the uh some of the
challenges and demands that there had
been say 15 20 20 years ago nationally
and hey things were on a reasonably even
keel having said that
nhs dentistry in greater manchester has
only ever been at the level of circus 65
um
for the local population nationally it's
been between 55 and 65 so we have her in
greater manchester being at the higher
end of that um
but clearly that means that there's been
members of the population who either
have access to independent and private
dentistry either because they chose to
or because they felt that mhs dentistry
wasn't available we also have people who
choose not to access dentistry for their
own reasons we know that a number of
people find you know dentistry scary and
yeah
and people who choose only to access
dentistry as and when they require it
for uh urgent treatment
and so things were things were
relatively stable prior to the pandemic
not great but relatively stable we then
went into the pandemic and clearly the
hair the mouth area is you know
covered central as some of my dental
colleagues had tell me and operating
hitting and around the mouth is it
presents significant challenge around
transfer
of the virus and her hurt and as a
result there was a national direction
from the chief dental office for england
instructing dentistry across the country
to suspend services in march
2020 that hey that that was then revoked
three or four months later but grant her
it meant that services and gradually
started operating again because the
coverage risk was still significant so
services were able to start operating
with enhanced protect protective
equipment specialist equipment
um allowing significant time in between
patients to allow for ventilation of the
surgeries um yeah
and hurt so actually even as services
recommenced they were clearly not
delivering at the same level that they
had been previously and as a result
during the period of code our access
levels you know
significantly dropped i've heard
over 70 percent less than they have been
pre-coded all of those people who
require who had previously been
accessing services then obviously expect
to access services now
along with those people who would
regularly and routinely access services
now so we have a significant demand
coming from the public seeking to access
their dental practice
as if that wasn't uh difficult enough
because of the delayed presentation and
those people who didn't access during
during kobit it means that treatment
needs have been exacerbated as well so
for those patients who are now accessing
the services the head that many have
more complex treatment need that takes
longer to
to address so even though our dental
practices are sustaining their nhs
commitment in terms of time commitment
it means that the throughput of patience
is significantly lower than it would be
normally and all of this means that um
although
what i'm pleased to say is that in
trafford we've maintained a stable
provision of nhs dental
provision we haven't lost practices
which has been the experience in some
other parts of greater manchester and
definitely across the country
we've maintained that capacity but it
means that the throughput for patients
isn't as a as quick and as high as it
was pre here pre-coded so all of that
presents a very challenging position for
her for our dental services and for the
local population um
so so um just here clearly we've had
lots of feedback from members of the
public through the complaints route but
also through
local elected members like yourself um
seeking to understand the challenges
seeking her
advice as to how to access services and
particularly where they have treatment
needs um and her
uh our local dental committee colleagues
work very closely with healthwatch in
order to seek to support that that that
response and access for patients but we
here we recognize that overall capacity
without significant increase not just in
financial resource we could throw money
at it but actually
resources and capacity of workforce and
her dental facilities what is it here is
what would actually respond to respond
to that increased demand
and
so what have we done to her to seek to
support this we've here um
most critically we've increased the
capacity of urgent dental care services
so that those patients who absolutely
need dental treatment who you know are
in pain or have you know broken teeth
etc are able um as far as possible to
access their services so we've increased
the capacity of the the treatment
services and also increased the capacity
of the dental helpline to be able to
respond that
it does mean
that doesn't mean that every hair we can
absolutely guarantee everybody
to be able to access but
but the services have done what they can
in order to respond to that hurt to that
need
and uh that increased her access
capacity was built in during the pand
pandemic in response to
the drop in access but we've sustained
that across greater manchester and we're
continuing to say that sustain that at
least through to march uh 2023 because
the current demand levels are such that
we need to ensure that that capacity is
there and we will review to uh yeah as
we get towards the end of that time as
to whether that need is continued to be
required during it through next year um
my expectation is that it will be i
don't think there's any quick fix to the
destabilization that the that kovid has
had on our services
um but just to say that those challenges
are reflected not through just through
dental practices but across the whole of
dental services so includes our
secondary care colleagues who have
increased waiting times for oral surgery
specialist orthodontics services etc and
been reflected through our specialist
services in the community
as well
so so in order to
address some of the impact of that
because this isn't just all about the
dental services
we want to address some of the
challenges that it presents to
inequalities in our local community
and her general oral health oral health
isn't just what happens when you sit in
the dental chair oral health is what
happens every year every day um so so
we've had a number of responses to that
um we've been working with dental
practices to help for them to prioritize
clinical clinical conditions
particularly those that directly are
impacted by their dental treatment and
their oral health so cancer pathways um
cardiology services etc but also
obviously patients in pain and
predominantly
the focus for children because um
because here the impact of uh on
children on their well-being and on
their future lives is significant so in
order to support children
we've introduced a scheme called
child-friendly dental practice we would
hope all practices were child-friendly
but this is about a focus um using her
expertise in certain practices that are
more
aligned to working with children more
experience in working with children and
the challenges that children bring in
order to first and foremost reduce
waiting times um that may present if the
child had to go into specialist services
but also
part of the friendly dental scheme works
with um our local authority colleagues
around ensuring a dental home for looked
after children and meeting such true
responsibilities um for up for our
looked after outlook after children and
i'm pleased to say that there's been a
real positive response around how how
well that uh that pathway is working we
also um
do work around population health and the
healthy living dental framework um is
something that looks at how
dental practices and dental teams can
contribute um within their local
community around her um health and
well-being it aligns very much with a
similar initiative that was introduced
nationally for community pharmacy but
it's something that we've targeted for
dental services and um here and here
are rolling that out across our dental
dental practices
i mentioned oral health um i uh i'm very
aware of the challenges not just for
children um around dental services and
oral health um
but but also for older people and
dependent adults and um one of the
things that was really we were able to
really able to accelerate during the the
kobe pandemic was online training and
one of the one of the packages of our
online training has been a package
called mouth care matters which
helps with or her oral care for
individuals we have a a a a scheme that
looks at children but also um for care
homes and residential homes supporting
and carers to to support the dependent
adults and what i'm pleased to say is
that um where cqc have assessed hair
care homes that's been her um her
evidence
presented of the mouth care matters
programme um which has contributed to
her outstanding her um her results for
her for the from cqc assessments so we
are hoping that that that program will
really be able to move forward and
support um across the board in terms of
improving care for her for our dependent
adults
so
that's um
a very rapid i recognize a summary of
the position across our dental services
the challenges that were presented
through covid and how we've looked to
respond to them we're also um here
currently working with the local dental
committees and health watch colleagues
at um a a new dental access plan looking
at how we can take some of the
flexibilities through the delegated
commissioning responsibilities that nhs
greater manchester received in july in
order here to address
those challenges that i've described um
and that part of that will be working
around public and patient
communications to help the public
understand how to access services
appropriately some of the challenges
around recall intervals so we still have
a lot of people seeking to to attend
every six months despite the fact that
they're orally fit and healthy and don't
don't need to attend every six months um
yeah
so part of the plan is around public
communications but also how we can work
with practices to open up access for new
patients patients who
haven't regularly been seen by hurt by a
practice because because that's where
our our key challenges are at the moment
while sustaining that access to urgent
dental care that i described earlier on
so it has so that's around
primary dental care services
this evening i also wanted to take the
opportunity to discuss what hurt some of
the developments that we're looking at
for our specialist community dental
services not her
which here across greater manchester or
here we have um
bridgewater who
did deliver in trafford and also in um
seven of the other localities of greater
manchester and then in manchester city
um manchester foundation trust deliver
the community-based services and in
salford um northern care alliance
deliver their
their community-based services but
across those services and we recognize
that uh because of the nature of the
services that they tend to be uh operate
part-time in her in dental facilities
because they operate across different
parts of the community what we've been
looking at is how do we make better use
of our um then our nhs estate not just
for dental services but for all of the
services that are demanding
accommodation and uh as such we are we
are reviewing how we might be able to
take part-time services consolidate them
in order to provide a full-time service
from a a specialist environment and then
release accommodation that hurt to meet
some of the other demands in the in the
health care system and what her and
bridgewater have been very keen to look
at that withers in trafford
and look at
moving from three part-time facilities
in seymour grave in conway road and in
partington to consolidate into altering
the health and well-being of and i know
we've already had some discussion this
evening around um
the hub at altering them but uh but
these considerations have been
first and foremost look at the
opportunity that the the hub
accommodation provides but also what are
the wider benefits if we were to do this
and her her and her key to key to this
are that in particular in particular the
uh the specialist service um is
co-located with the dental practice the
dental practice is extremely keen to
expand and and further develop um but
it's limited because of the
accommodation arrangements and if
bridgewater were to move out and that
would mean that there wouldn't be a loss
of dental services in partington but
actually their general dental services
would be able to expand and more
appropriately meet local need but what
part of the development of our community
services will be around shared care
opportunities so working with our dental
practices so where pattington residents
may need some of that specialist advice
and support you know there would still
be that access to services whether that
was physical access um traveling to the
new venue or whether that was uh you
know through the dental practice that's
remaining in partington similarly um in
the other here in the other venues that
we have other services that are
extremely keen to to expand their
primary care network and services that
are desperate for accommodation and so
we see it as a real opportunity and a
win-win not just for consolidating and
developing the especially dental
services but also supporting those other
services who are seeking accommodation
locally
as i say um
very happy to have further
discussion and questions and um we're
there with your permission chair i would
invite and the appropriate colleagues to
respond uh subject to what questions are
kind thank you thank you very much
that um
becomes rap too
[Music]
thank you for the presentation
uh i suppose mine's a pretty simple
question
you you do say and it's in the report
that we
have 36 uh general dentist
dental services
um
and
uh they
contracted activity of 42
000 is it 400 is that 42 000
um
[Music]
units of dental
activity yeah
for 420
yeah
yeah um the simple question really is
and i don't think it's answered in in
all the papers that we've got is when
will we get back to normal
and how are we going to get back to
normal
because these are the issues you know
the basic issues really for people i
speak to is getting appointments like
they used to be i'll get appointments
from their dentist
and that doesn't seem to be happening
the second point
the patient feedback responding to
feedback
um it says although a large number of
enquiries are being received these are
not being taken forward as formal
complaints
and are generally dealt with informally
what does that mean does it mean that
they're not taking on board quite
frankly because obviously you need to
monitor
you know that feedback to be able to get
a sense of what the people out there are
actually thinking and feeling
so it's just so simple points really
[Music]
thank you i'll answer the uh the second
one first if i may and then yeah invite
colleagues around the first one so in
terms of the complaints
informal resolution is where it's
resolved at a local level between the
patient and the practice
and rather than going through the formal
complaints group through nhs england so
hey so absolutely
all complaints are taken seriously and
man and managed and where complaints are
managed uh by the dental practice
practices are required annually to
report on the number of complaints that
they've received and managed in that
manner so we do we do monitor
the level of complaints
the formal route is through nh singling
where it's taken up and follows the nhs
complaints procedure so it has so
so absolutely all complaints are dealt
with here and this one it responded to
it just depends on the route at a high
level though surely we need to
understand what people are actually
saying at the dentist whether they get
it you know an informal
uh sort of
um
you know
word from
the dentist that you know
everything's you know you can have an
appointment or whatever
um because you're complaining about it
we need a sense really of what people
are actually thinking and feeling i i
can guess what it is
um because i've had my own experiences
so
um
so yeah so and when are we going to get
back to normal i think that's
the main thing absolutely and and your
guess is
i would say is absolutely spot-on
nationally dental access is the largest
matter and nhs complaints nationally um
and if a complaint is responded
informally by the practice and the
patient isn't happy with that outcome
they are able to escalate it through the
formal route so
to ensure that it's addressed
appropriately so but in terms of
when we're able to get back to normal
that's a very good question
and uh being perfectly honest i couldn't
give you a direct answer because
who we don't know
and uh what is clear is that it will be
a new normal um because actually the the
delivery of dental services has changed
with uh hair because covered continues
to be in the community and continues to
be a
challenge and so our
dental workforce um continued to use
enhanced ppe to her and her infection
control measures in order to protect
both themselves and her and patients
um
and the yeah as we say
although practices are
retaining their their time commitment
um the throughput of patience is still
lower than it than it was historically
but uh i'll ask um vijay in order to
comment as well from his experience
and his colleagues experience
i'd probably say the dental situations
changed now to what it was pre-culved
um we've got workforce issues since
colby and probably a little bit of
brexit as well
european dentists nurses hygienist
therapists can't register with the
governing body gdc
as easily as they used to do before
and the gdc is also taking time to build
up their services to put them through
their exams and
get them their registrations i think i'm
not sure what a percentage is but in
nowhere near what they were pre-covered
and also dental practices operate as
independent businesses
and we're susceptible to the environment
around us where the cost of living going
up gas electricity and things like that
but unfortunately nhs income hasn't
and because of that it's hard to recruit
nhs dentists it's hard to recruit nhs
nurses
any new dentists or anyone looking for
work are looking for private only so a
lot of them are leaving the nhs
so that's causing workforce issues which
is going to make it harder to sort of
recover to where we were precovered
and also during covid a lot of dental
nurses hygienists and therapists left
the profession
and have sort of took jobs elsewhere and
that's caused more workforce issues
it doesn't look very good does it no
counselor brophy
and recognising the problems in
dentistry are
not just related to trafford but a
national issue in terms of the things
you've just mentioned
and so i think my
points are just going to focus locally
because we can't do a lot about the
situation with
some of the workforce issues apart from
sort of local initiatives
um
but i was quite
pleased to hear your presentation
because i think you covered more or less
everything in the report in a lot of
detail and but i think one point that
stood out that you said that sort of
then
what happens in dentistry is more that
than what happens in the dentist chair a
lot of people think oh you just go to
the dentist when you've got toothache
but in the area where i've worked most
of my life a lot of health issues are
related to dentistry which people don't
appreciate
so you mentioned some of these things so
having poor oral health being linked
with
wider health problems like diabetes and
you mentioned heart problems
and eating and nutrition clearly is very
much related to the state of your oral
health and your gums and a lot of people
in hospitals have got very poor
um
dental issues so it does mean that sort
of nutrition and hydration can can be
quite difficult
and so i'm more interested in
and sort of things we can do locally to
improve dentistry i'm quite interested
in the preventative measures as well
because i think um we talk a lot at this
committee about sort of preventative
measures and at the health and
well-being board about um health
promotion and health prevention but we
don't very often talk about dentistry i
have to say i think it's one of those
issues because it kind of sits
slightly separate to the nhs compared to
so many of the other services that we
it's unrecognized in terms of just how
much poor dental health links with
deprivation and other health issues and
i think the state of people's oral
health is is also so much linked to
their
deprivation levels as well um that's
down to probably a mixture of reasons in
terms of like access to dentistry
whether you can afford it or not but
it's also
um having the sort of knowledge of how
to
and you know self-care and
when you're not in a good health
situation or a good living situation
it's often
teeth that are sort of neglected with
mental health and
so i think i i'd like to hear more about
how
the proposals you got here link into the
other sort of health insurance i was
really interested to read and hear about
you explaining the altering hub because
clearly we've talked about that a lot
and dentistry is is an important area
and particularly the preventative side
of it to link that into the wider health
and but i also think um
the points made by the other councillor
about um sort of access to dentistry as
well and
is there anything we can be doing better
in trafford to get that access but also
in terms of the prevention
how widely are you reaching those areas
like the care homes
where kind of oral health and dentistry
is is key to whether people are sort of
comfortable and healthy in care homes
and in hospitals as well
thank you um in terms of oral health uh
yeah
i heard the
responsibilities for oral health
improvement actually sit as a statutory
responsibility to the local authority
rather than dental commissioning what we
try and do is through our dental
commissioning complement and support
you know and enhance um
those local initiatives and look at how
we can support that from a greater
manchester perspective hence um
some of the online toolkits and training
and uh and working with our uh our
locality-based oral health colleagues
and public health colleagues so so a lot
of that does flow through um public
health uh uh
that on a local basis
and yeah you know
pick that up
separately um but what
what we also try and do through
the initiatives such as healthy living
dental and dentistry is
bring her then the dental workforce and
the dental team in to support and lead
some of that because her that clinical
leadership you know
about her provides um a real impetus for
the local local population so so rather
than going into too much detail about
you know local initiatives that sit with
the local authority
but um in terms of what we can do around
improving overall overall access we have
commenced uh peaceful work looking at um
what the opportunities may be to support
the workforce development vijay just
explained some of those real challenges
around recruitment not just um the
difference her um
her sources of recruitment but also the
challenge i've heard um
a lot of
the workforce seeking to not work for
the nhs work independently and privately
and so so we've got
as part of our dental access planning a
work stream around recruitment and
within that it's not just for dentists
and nurses but starting to look at the
opportunities to use wider dental
workforce hygiene hygienists and
therapists that will help with some of
the
health inequalities and the oral health
improvement elements as well
so
okay we've got to bring helen guys in
now
um thank you so from our perspective at
a local level um we
there's a number of different
initiatives that are running at the
moment so we do have support from
colleagues at bridgewater we have um
the equivalent of one whole time
equivalent oral health promoter who
works
and and supports work that we do um and
is guided by jane hynes who's our
healthy weight
and physical activity lead so just to
give you an idea we've done um
outside of the oral health work
in terms of the officer our health
visiting teams are always very keen on
ensuring um i can't remember what it's
called now but first teeth matter so
ensuring that families form good habits
they start brushing and weaning is
really healthy in terms of ensuring that
the children have a good start into oral
health
um our oral health promoters have been
working on doing training so they've
done lots of training that we've kind of
directed them to areas of need so they
started initially for children aged zero
to five in areas of high deprivation
again about forming good habits and and
there were um
initiatives involving toothbrushes and
paste as well to families who required
them but they've done training to staff
who support our children's residential
care homes because we know that that's
an area of inequality
care homes and
communities where learning disability
because we're aware of the inequality
there in terms of oral health
it obviously links into our food and
schools initiatives and principles of
kind of good food and reduced sugar and
obesity as well i think the area that we
are most concerned about the moment is
the impact of cost of living in terms of
quality of food we hear stories of
families who are living in poverty
may
give their children for example
condensed milk in their baby bottles
which any dentist will tell you is
catastrophic for baby teeth so we need
to just think wider at the moment in
terms of the cost of living but i i
think we're very keen as a public health
department to ensure that where we can
build oral health in with the capacity
we've got that we do do that
so the one area that wasn't looked at is
for older populations as well like care
homes and
house
so often oral health is leads to poor
outcomes in sort of older populations as
well so
yeah
so we have done training into care homes
and um
i don't know if diane has any further
information but that has been looked at
through the nutrition and hydration work
as well
thank you we have we have agreed with
public health a whole series of training
into care homes nutrition hydration
oral health etc and it really is
improving the quality of support and not
only around how to support people when
often their behaviors and complexities
make it quite difficult but also how it
supports staff to spot problems quicker
and know who to seek help from so it's
been really really helpful and it will
continue
thank you to hear about that work
okay
counselor hi i've got a
quick question i was pleased to hear you
talk about child-friendly uh dental
practices and
um i've read obviously in the report
about children with additional needs and
people with additional needs can you
just clarify if um there is something
that's just called an extraction only
list when we talk about treating um
children with additional needs whereby
they don't they don't have access to the
full range of dental treatment so they
don't get offered like um fillings and
stuff like that once these children
present they just have the tooth removed
could you confirm if that's the case
um i suppose if i could pick her up i'm
barry hutton i'm the director of
the dental network for bridgewater we
provide the specialist service um i
don't think that's our focus so we'll
we'll deliver
dental care that's appropriate to the
individual to the child or to the
adult with um with special needs and and
we will
concentrate on maintenance
so in terms of maintaining good oral
health
and depend on the complexities of the
individual it will depend on that
intervention that we deliver some of
that intervention has to be done in
hospital under sedation and it might
result in extraction but part of the
service and the work that our clinicians
do is largely about prevent prevention
and we have a good level of access up on
uptake from both children special care
children especially adults to maintain
their
their oral health and it's largely about
maintenance really so we don't have to
do some of those really difficult
interventions but there isn't an
extraction only list
hello i'm heather fairfield i'm the
chair of
trafford healthwatch
and the vice chair of the 10 um health
watches in greater manchester
um as has been said in the presentation
we have had quite a lot of involvement
around dentistry and over the past
couple of years i think we've had
more that well more than 50 percent of
the
um inquiries and complaints that
we have had so it's really significant
numbers um
and we produced a report
and it was sent up to healthwatch
england who i think then took it along
with other areas as well who had
complained about dental services um and
i think that you know then we had some
of the responses coming from government
um
i think that the um one of the main
complaints really
was about
people being asked to go private
rather than being on the nhs and that
was quite a lot of complaints around
that and that is really related to uh
the cost
um and of course and we've already
mentioned that with the um financial
situation as it is and that is likely to
get uh very much worse i think
um
we've noticed that the secretary of
state is going to shine a light on
dentistry
um so that will be uh interesting to see
um
if anything uh comes of that
um
we do understand the um constraints that
you've had over the last couple of years
um and we understand the issues about
workforce there's almost every
part of the nhs is suffering from
workforce issues um and it's not going
to be an easy and easy fix for anybody
but i think that if we can um
i think my major concern is really
around um
children
um and i don't know if any of you have
ever been to the children's hospital but
you can hardly get in the door for the
number of children that are in there
and because their parents have never
taken them to a dentist and because
they're frightened to undergo
any treatment
so i would like a little bit of focus i
think
directed to the
children's um hospital uh dentistry
because i think that that's part of the
equation that you know we're missing at
the moment
thanks
okay thank you
council
council hartley
[Music]
uh thank you chad just um following up
on that last point actually around
particularly children's dentistry um
and i i agree with the observation about
the children's hospital though
i have to say from my experience the the
the care at the dental unit at the
children's hospital is is outstanding
and um
um
so that leads on to a question which was
about the um
the specialist uh dental care the the
bridgewater provided care which part of
which is is pediatric dentistry
and the um
the proposal to to move those services
to to altering them which which
certainly sounds good on uh you know on
paper
will that um
generate additional capacity because
my experience of that service is it is
overstretched and it's very difficult to
get an appointment
um
i don't want to use my own
uh family as an exemplary in being a
counselor but um
we had a
a pediatric oncology referral and we
found it incredibly difficult to get an
appointment with the with the community
service um
so that sent us back to the to the
children's hospital and you know we're
getting great care there but
that that doesn't seem to work from my
perspective so i wonder if there's any
plans to increase the capacity along
with that relocation thank you
so in terms of capacity and workforces
the status quo is maintained by the
proposal i think what i would say in
terms of the leverage of the proposal
because there are
a number of part-time
surgeries in use across the three
existing premises
it leverages the opportunity imparting
to them for increased capacity by the
high street dental practice and of
course
what we would all want is that all
families all adults access you know your
primary care dental provider on a
regular basis you
you have an engagement and a
relationship with them and you feel
comfortable going back to see them so i
think that's what this proposal
leverages in terms of its delivery
but there isn't any additional capacity
there's no reduction in capacity but
there's no additional capacity
and i think its focus is on improvement
of quality of service and i think this
really is the focus of the of the
development so leveraging the
opportunity of partington is the
additional for the high street and then
the improvement in
service quality for the specialist
provider
council leicester
thank you my question sort of ties into
that a little bit um it was around the
specialist dental care as well and the
relocation which in a lot of respects
sounds really good and it would use the
health and well make good use of the
health and well-being hub which we've
already spoken about tonight but i want
it but it is very much at one end of the
borough and
obviously some of the existing sites
particularly see more grove at the other
end of the borough and it's going back
to the question of transport really
which ties in with the back to the minor
injuries unit as well is work going to
be done probably in both groups in
actual fact with transport for greater
manchester to actually try and
um improve services so we actively
recruit
public transport services that will
support this relocation as opposed to
just sort of being at the the women of
transport of greater manchester and the
services that are currently being
provided
there's an opportunity there but it will
involve that work with the transport
services
i i don't think that's something that
we've picked up in terms of our leverage
of of that engagement with the transport
authority but i think collectively
that's our opportunity isn't it to um to
to bring to bear our influence in that i
think uh the focus is on specialist
delivery and improving quality of care
and clearly in that regard you know we
we look at the wider impacts of access
and i think this proposal in terms of
delivery makes use of a very
well a fantastic facility altering as
we've we've heard today we all know
and i think it might help with the
leverage of increased transport links
into into the ultra locality sets i'm
sure we can
we can pick up outside
okay cancer acting
yeah um can i just ask her a question
um
around the gentle
the the general dentist
service providers
uh
with contracted
activity of the 420 000 units
so if they're contracted for that
are they delivering on that
so
nationally the con that the contracted
activity delivery
um
is falling short of that
and so nationally uh indication is that
it's circus 70
of um dental contracted activity and
that's across the board nationally which
indicates the impact that um kobe has
had and
here as you say the difference in terms
of throughput
of patience
which is one of the challenges that we
have of the national contract and i'm
not going to go into the technicalities
of the national contract but it very
much counts
the widgets those units of dental
activity rather than um
patient patient throughput
patient numbers or or quality so part of
what um our considerations and our
discussions around our dental access
planning and the nhs go to manchester is
looking at how we can work with the
national regulations in the national
contract but also
um have a focus on quality and a focus
on um meeting
her patient needs but by opening up
access for new patients as well as
ensuring that all patients who require
urgent care
have urgent care so in direct answer to
your question it's not being delivered
that's not a reflection of local
dentists that's a national challenge
an issue
so who
did
did they get money back from the dentist
so the base at the basis of the contract
the national contract
is that um there's an annual contract
value and there's an annual cut activity
and if they fall short on the activity
they have a propos the same proportion
removed of their contract value so so
that's the incentive to deliver however
and being here being here
currently the difficulty is that if that
means that a third of your contract
value is at risk and it's going to be
taken away from you it makes sustaining
both business and service extremely
challenging and and so part of our
access plan is how do we provide that
assurance for for practices to be able
to
to
to commit to delivery
whilst also holding them to account for
that service delivery
can i just ask
more specifically around orthodontics i
think the reason i'm asking i was at the
dentist on monday and i told my dentist
i was coming here and
his immediate response was ask them
about orthodontics because uh i think
because i think they were just
discussing how long the waiting lists
were for it and some of the problems and
that they they really don't seem to be
catching up at the moment sort of with
the post covid's
era
absolutely um but what i will say
honestly is that the waiting list
pre-credited were challenging as well
and part of the challenge of
orthodontics is this there's two two
elements one is the nature of the demand
for orthodontics because um
orthodontics is here here um here
the attempt is to
to manage access in accordance with
clinical treatment need
but actually
a lot of demand is hurt is patient
driven rather than clinical and need
driven um and so
constantly trying to address that
balance the flip side of that also is it
comes back to the discussion around
workforce so a number of our uh um
orthodontic units in secondary care
across greater manchester and across the
northwest and nationally and i've had
real challenges in recruiting
consultants over the past five years um
which has meant that um yeah
their ability to manage um weight here
at waiting times has been challenged as
well so here so yeah so what that leads
us to is two things one is um
we're working with primary care
orthodontic services to see how to
ensure that anything that can be
delivered in primary care is being
delivered in primary care not not um
adding to
hospital waiting lists it also means
that we're
here we've got ongoing review of those
waiting lists to ensure that the
patients are appropriate and suitable
for nhs treatment and also we recognize
that actually
within the numbers um that her there's
off and the waiting times often by the
time someone's offered an appointment
they may well have gone through a
different route either chosen not to
proceed progress with the treatment or
have
taken a private treatment option so
actually we're constantly um uh looking
at um how to refresh the waiting list in
order to ensure that it
appropriately reflects the need for the
services so it's a it's an ongoing
challenge and i'm pleased that you you
raised it um yeah because it needs to be
recognized um yeah
and
so what we're doing is trying to manage
the demand to make sure that it's
appropriate and also support the
workforce recruitment to deliver that
service as well
okay
thank you
well that's been
very
helpful very interesting i have to say
that
i think that it's there's more issues in
dentistry than we expected
when we focused on this as a as an item
for this
committee so
i think i feel a little bit
shell-shocked
from
some of the situations we're in uh and
it does lead me to think that it is a
subject that we will need to come back
to um
in a suitable
uh gap of time
and to give some time for more progress
to be made but uh
very helpful very interesting and thank
you very much for for all of your
contribution with that and
thank you to the committee as well for
that
um
so we're on item seven the integrated
care system update it's a verbal update
okay thank you thank you gareth james
from fm nhs greater manchester trafford
locality team
formerly the council officer of the ccg
so
um
the conscious of time i've been asked to
give a verbal update so i'm going to
keep this quite brief i'm going to do a
bit of a look back because i think this
is the first update we've had since
we've moved to the new arrangements and
so so a bit of a recap and a bit of sort
of clarity around some of
the terminology we're now using because
it's not
as clear as perhaps as it could be and
then just some of the details of the
developments that we've made in the
locality and we've talked about the
locality board already you know some of
those things so
so just a few things for me to to start
with in terms of recap so so you'll be
aware that the 2022 health and care act
was delayed so it didn't come into being
on the first of april so that was the
first of july
2022 so it's only two and a half months
ago so so that involved the dissolution
of over 200 i think it was 212 ccgs at
the time
sorry on the establishment of 42
integrated care systems so that's what
we're talking about now when we are we
operating in an ics as we call it now
the confusion is there are lots of three
letter acronyms icb icp ics
so just to clarify that
in all of the 42
ics's
are two statutory parts to that
integrated care system so an icb so
integrated care board which is the new
statutory nhs body
and in manchester the naming convention
is nhs greater manchester integrated
care
and also there's an integrated care
partnership at the gm level and that's
where the nhs body comes together with
all of the other partners so with the 10
localities
sorry local authorities and the other
partners across health and well-being
and the wider determinants so that's
called the gm um icp you know there's a
naming convention for that
so on the first of july so two and a
half months ago the majority of the
staff functions and funding from the
ccgs called the sender organization
transferred across on the first july and
that involved over 2000 staff from the
former ccgs transferred across and it's
fair to say and i think in the briefings
you've had before that was a really
challenging time for the ccg and the
staff in particular
so i'm pleased to say that day one came
and went and it was fairly seamless
still some challenges but most of the
staff and functions transferred across
and most of the staff from the ctg had
little change to their role so some of
the teams did start to it differently on
day one for example the finance team but
the vast majority are still doing very
similar roles in the same locality as
they were prior to the first of july
i think it's fair to say we're still
working through some of the detail
exactly what the new arrangements are
going to be and it's recognized very
much by the icb board and mark fisher
the chief exec he still describes a year
of transformation and transition
2223 so a lot of what we're working
through both locally but also across gm
will sort of transition and develop as
we move through towards the end of march
23.
so just a bit more about the icb so it's
an integrated care board and as i said
they've inherited
the statutory functions of the 10 ccgs
before
and they're quite a distinct priorities
outlined in the health and care act so
just to mention a few of those and it is
around a population health and
population care approach and so that
is really sort of important and it leads
to
some of the discussion that we've had
already is a key priority is around the
tackling of health inequalities and it's
very much the focus of the localities
too
but still
within the wider context of value for
money because there's a significant
financial challenge and although a
balanced financial plan has been
submitted by the whole of gm for 2223
there's a significant amount of
financial risk in that plan so that's
the context we're working with and then
it's moving on to the integrated care
partnership that has a key purpose of
developing the strategy for for
addressing the health and care needs of
the population
of gm and i guess two points to draw out
there two really important points are
that the health and wellbeing board so
the 10 health and wellbeing boards are
really integral in this in developing
that strategy with gm icp and also the
icps are subject to local government
health scrutiny so exactly what that
would look like i don't know but this
kind of process
will continue as well at the gm level as
well at the locality so i think that's a
really positive step and that's clear
within the health and care act
so just moving on to localities or
places as you'll have heard them call so
so they are an integral part of the
integrated care system and you know
our clear focus of the traffic locality
team is developing
that locality focus so previous
briefings i think from tom on my left
and sarah radcliff who is my colleague
for the ccg i think concentrated on the
development of some of the governance
arrangements and the locality and also
the locality leadership model so you'll
be aware now that sarah told the chief
executive council is also the place lead
for health and care integration so that
really signals an integrated approach i
think
more than anything i think so
that's really positive so some of the
governance that we've put in place now
similar to other localities but specific
to trafford is a trafford locality board
so again we talked about that before
with a varied agenda so so that's where
all of the partners come together from
you know include healthcare um
um healthwatch and heather sits on the
board as well come together on a monthly
basis to discuss the priorities and the
delivery in a nutshell it's a delivery
of the locality plan you know that all
of our partners have agreed
and so we come together at the moment
that's a fairly informal arrangement
even though we've agreed some fairly
detailed terms of reference and a
co-chairing arrangement between the
leader of the council and the chair of
our local gp board so again a really
positive move that's still fairly
informal we expect when we get further
clarity on the actual delegations from
the icb at gm level down to locality
that will become a far more formal
arrangement and we will become either a
joint committee with or a subcommittee
of the icb so that's a bit of technology
but that means that will become a far
more formal arrangement where decisions
are made on those delegations in a joint
fashion so that again is a really
positive step forward
provider collaboration and providers
coming together to support this is a key
element of the act as well so we've
developed our
traffic provider collaborative and dan
is the co-chair of um
the
locality provider collaborative and
that's
necessarily what we describe as a
delivery engine for the locality plan so
that will come together to deliver the
locality plan but also you know the
delegation that we've received from from
icb that i've described and some of the
top priorities all of the partners have
agreed that you'll be very familiar with
of the development of the neighborhood
model which is front and center
throughout all that we're doing in the
locality and also discharge and making
that as resilient and as good as we can
to support
flow throughout the whole of the health
and care system so two of
of three top priorities there and also
just the final piece of the jigsaw in
terms of governance is a clinical and
practitioner senate
where the clinicians and the
practitioners come together to provide
the oversight and support to everything
we do so again that's a really positive
step forward i think to have that
clinical insight into everything we're
doing as a locality
so to summary
summarize chair i guess
two and a half months in if we've made
significant progress there are still
uncertainty so i can't say exactly here
today what the delegations will be so
what
exactly the accountabilities will be to
the locality but we're expecting that to
move really quickly now in the next sort
of two or three weeks and so what i
would suggest for the next briefing we
come probably in a few months would be
to bring some more detail intact
to to describe what the locality board
will be accountable for and then the
impact that will have on the trafford
locality in its residence so
i think i'll pause there i know i've
sort of raced through that and used
quite a bit of terminology which i tried
not to but it but it is inevitable i'm
afraid with with what we're dealing with
how poor thank you thank you well i'm
gonna
start questions by asking you a very
basic one
and that is
if things
had
started to go wrong
with the
changeover
how would we have known how would it
have manifested itself where would have
it impacted
[Music]
i think it was a very good question i
guess it could be nothing far extreme of
that it could have affected health care
and patient experience but i think i
think what we would have witnessed more
is more uncertainty i guess in the
system for the staff and also for the
providing care and within health and
care economy so
it's hard to say in the worst case i
guess it could be quite catastrophic but
all we were doing i guess is moving from
10 statutory mentioned bodies into one
so that part of it was more like a
government exercise what's far more
important is how that moves forward and
we work with systems
both in the locality and not as
individual organizations the key thrust
of all of this is working as a
partnership so i think the risk of doing
that
is very small and the games are huge in
terms of working systems
okay and
the old question what's
likely to keep you awake at four o'clock
in the morning
i guess his performance and we've heard
about a couple of things like dance
history as well it's top of the list of
patient care but
we reviewed through the locality board
now we review patient care and outcomes
but also the performance against the
standards
and performance is really important to
where we needed to be that's where it
was pretty pandemic so
so that's a clear focus and it's it's
trying to see improvements in in patient
care of course
i'm on account of my trade and the
financial position is significantly
challenging and if we're not careful
that
you know significant impact so the
conversation we're having is to
try and be as productive as we can
just to follow on
questions sorry i'll put my microphone
on has anything gone wrong it all sounds
really positive and i know it was a huge
huge undertaking but have there been any
critical incidents has patient care
being impacted in any way
do you foresee anything
um
yeah exactly reverse events
any risk of that
i think no further risk from the changes
we've made i guess i would summarize of
course we see we see risk to patient
care and we see incidents coming through
on a very regular basis unfortunately
but we've seen those when we were a
clinical commissioning group and we were
dealing with those pretty much in a
similar way i don't think the risk is
greater of that it's not changed
no no i think there's an opportunity to
reduce that because we are working very
closely i mean in trafford we have done
for years i know but across the patch it
is a wider determinant it's not health
and health organizations trying to solve
these problems on their own so i do see
that as a real opportunity but
it's a huge challenge with the money and
where we are with performance like we've
talked about dentistry is there are a
number of those areas which are really
concerning
are there any key issues i mean
obviously you've talked more generally
about the integration across gm are
there any key issues specifically in
trafford that we as a committee
should be aware of
that have occurred or may occur as a
result of this integration
not as a result of the integration i
would say no
no
i issues about otherwise well yeah i
mean last night we talked about
dentistry yeah on a regular basis i'm
sure they come here we talk about access
to primary care and a number of thinking
sorry access and waiting lists to mental
health services is something that we're
really focusing on and that's in
addition to the very high profile sort
of waiting lists around cancer and
elective care and the recovery from that
which obviously is high profile and very
important but there are others
perhaps less high profile ones that we
concentrate on in the locality so things
that we were already aware of so
nothing's changed significantly
okay thank you very much
council acton
yeah
it's
on similar vein really of the
two two questions that have already been
asked um but it's about performance
indicators really
in in terms of
of how
you know what
what are those performance indicated for
yourselves
to
you know to to bed this service down
um in in terms of that integration
because obviously there's a lot of flux
um that will be out there and there'll
be certain
um you know performance
indicators
i would have thought that we could
actually
look at and
uh scrutinize quite frankly
yeah i think that's a really good
question and something that we're
grappling with across the whole of gm so
it's not
totally clear what we will measure in
the locality and what will be measured
once across gm but that's something that
we're working with and talking about on
a weekly basis
i guess that you know there are various
levels of how we monitor performance and
there's a multitude of targets ranging
from the national constitutional
standards there's a target we have in
our own planning that we set ourselves
but also some things that we
we
set aside in gm and the locality which
are particularly important to either
locality or the gm population as well so
you know so i think it's a great idea
that we bring back some of that back to
you to a future
future meeting some of those you'll be
very familiar with because they're very
high profile but someone perhaps not so
familiar with um so so we're working
through you know i describe the provider
collaborative so exactly what we're
going to monitor so that's something of
a live discussion that all of our
providers and are coming together so
what's really important to traffic so
what are we gonna monitor so that's
probably perhaps the focus that we
should have here rather than national
sort of constitutional standards because
i think i think you've probably done
that many times yeah i think i think
it'd be really helpful for the uh
scrutiny committee to to bring something
to us in terms of those indicators yeah
that's time to come in on on that with
that
thank you tom maloney program director
across health and care um for the
council and for nhs gm trafford locality
team um
just building on gara's point i think
it's worth mentioning the work that we
are trying to push with all our partners
that sit around the provider
collaborative board table so there there
are sort of prototypes of what we would
describe as our provider collaborative
dashboard which links into
the two big key priorities that gareth
has mentioned and we're actually taking
that to our september meeting in three
weeks and two and a half weeks time
so i think we will be in a in a good
position to bring some of that back as
that matures over the coming months
and also to just mention on a more
granular level detail is that we take
the system oversight framework as well
although it's not ready for next week's
locality board on tuesday um we have
agreed um a previous meeting that we
would take that back on a regular basis
so we are holding ourselves to account
on whether or not we're making a
difference and then just the last point
would be that through our engagement
working group and i think i've
referenced this at the previous scrutiny
meeting there's a lot of work to not
just have the facts and figures but
actually the qualitative stories of
people and lived experience weaved
throughout that so we're making
decisions based on both the quantitative
and qualitative data and thank you thank
you
you wanted to come in yeah i was just
going to add to the points that gareth
made as well one of the areas that we do
continue to support is our staff as well
so the transition still
continues to have some degree of
uncertainty for some of the staff as
well as we move through
where they work at and what what roles
they work within as well so that that's
something we continuously do in three
garas leadership we're constantly
briefing the staff making sure we're
engaging with gm because we don't want
to lose people so it's about retaining
people and making sure we keep our
talent within trafford
thank you
council lester
thank you um i just wanted to ask about
the the is this more work being done
around the great manchester care record
and sort of developing that
i think i work in an area where the
borough the local authority and the main
provider are co-terminus and trafford's
got a lot of different providers it's a
very different situation and i'm just
thinking in terms of sort of you know
communication record keeping and
obviously the greatest matches care or
record as far as like this is a really
valuable
way of ensuring that people in different
organizations can
can find out about the patients and
understand what else is happening i
think it seems particularly important
here
no thank you i totally agree
you know it's a vital part of what we're
doing you know patients don't really
understand that a gp might not see
something that the hospital doctor sees
it's the nhs isn't it so i i'm still
aware that that's very much you know one
of the key priorities around the digital
program within gm so that hasn't changed
at all and it should be even easier to
to bring together now because the
providers are working far
closer together and the localities are
working closer together i know that it's
not perfect yet not all of the areas of
information are in the same place yet
but i know there's a there's a plan and
a work plan to bring that on stream
and it's prioritized
is there a requirement for all gps to
sign up to it because as far as we see
there seems to still be a mix
do they can they still up not can they
still opt out with sharing their sort of
their information what do they have to
do good question i haven't got the
detail i think in under their contract
perhaps there is an opt-out from some
things
and that could include the care record
but i think there is a duty to share
some information the band you know the
answer to that technically
so technically each independent
organization um has to make its own
determination as a data holder so gp
practices can
um effectively opt out
they have a duty to collaborate and um
there's work work going on around data
sharing agreements in order to overcome
any reason why they may or choose to opt
out in order to streamline and achieve
achieve the outcomes that get her cats
outlined
okay social care
because i have social care
diane wanted to come in anyway
so just just to reach it is a
complicated system and it's it's um
it's really important though that we
work to simplify things for people
receiving services isn't it so we have
four neighborhood teams that are
co-located with health and social care
we have joint management arrangements
for those health and social care teams
and we have a trafford local carer
organization that we're in partnership
with through section 75 for joint
delivery of those services we have a
data sharing agreement as part of that
process so that we can share that data
we all use the record um and and we're
building skills on that as we develop
social care is in the um the shared
record as well so that's really helpful
um and we were one of the forerunners on
some of that work in traffic so we've
got a great digital team here supporting
us
having mft who we met today as a key
partner is really important because
that's three
um and if you count uh mri which we have
a smaller activity out but at four of
our key hospital sites so it's sulfur
that's that's the other option inside
that we work with and we work very
closely with salford as well but it does
require a lot of effort from everyone to
keep on on top of things so we use a lot
of data dashboards to make sure that we
are tracking everything that's happening
and we also do lessons learned on where
things have not worked as well as they
should do where data sharing has become
a key issue so we can take that and then
put that into our plans to learn and
develop more
okay
thank you well uh as we've said it's an
item we'll be coming back to and further
reports so uh
thank you very much for tonight and we
look forward to
hearing of uh
progress further down the line
and that takes us to item eight the work
program and i'm gonna cheat a little bit
here because alex gave me such a good
uh run through on this earlier um i
think the best thing to do is ask alex
to take the committee
through it i hope you don't mind me
springing you on that alex i should have
said something soon
no that's perfectly fine um so you'll
have a you've got a few documents um as
part of the work program
the first is the work program itself
which is start lines um what's up coming
in the next couple of meetings running
up to the end of the year um committee
members have the opportunity in a moment
to put forward if they have any other
suggestions that they would like to add
for items over the course of the year
and then if you move past that uh you'll
come to
or is that at the very end that's at the
very end so before that i've got ahead
of myself
um
so far
you should have a couple of documents
one is oh
right i have not waited out so the work
program was part of the original uh
agenda
set that i have sent out the second pack
that was sent out also under the work
program uh covered the first item which
was
the uh suggested new template for the
committee uh it's basically exactly the
same as the last template but it just
asks people when they're bringing
reports to the committee
um to identify where the report links
into
the committee's
priorities which are reducing health
inequalities improving resident health
and well-being and improving access to
services so it just asks that when a
report is coming from any provider that
they'll just highlight where
how their report addresses those
priorities if possible
so that's for the committee to look at
and decide if you're happy with or if
you would like to make any amendments to
also if um officers would have any
suggestions how to improve that would be
uh welcome
and then the final three um pages are
um
the scrutiny topic assessment
criteria
and this is three topics that we'll put
forward at the last committee as
possible task and finish groups
the first was
access to gps
following the pandemic
i've
gone through what was raised at the last
committee and put it through the
assessment criteria um looking at that
and
i've given it a score
of against uh importance and impact and
it come out at seven i would like the
committee to have a look at that uh and
see if you would like to make any
adjustments or if you're happy with the
scarring
scoring 7 would mean that it's a
priority topic
so one that you'd want to look at
the second topic
to look at was the access to children
and young people's mental health
services following the pandemic
um
same criteria uh went through and that
came out again at a seven
and those are two very large pieces of
work so
um
if you were to do a task and finish
group
you'd only be able to do one of those
two and see they're equal in terms of
the scoring so it's up to yourselves
which um one you would like to do
and then the final one which was um
counselling involvement in ics community
engagement
and that came at a lower score of um
just
uh just five which puts in the possible
topic for scrutiny but i'd like to
highlight that um as it's working with
the ics and it's linking into what
they're already doing that would have a
lower impact in terms of the resource
requirement and so you could probably do
that alongside one of the first two
so that's what i've got if you've got
any questions i will do my best to
answer them
any
questions
counselor harshly
thank you chad sorry don't wish to put
on a meeting but um i was gonna mention
this separately after the meeting it was
something diane said around um
data and performance data so um
my own opinion is i i agree with those
those priorities um
the first two over the last one probably
but um
two of the indicators for
that that must be met are around poor
performing service
and high levels of dissatisfaction
and i suppose my my sort of query for
the committee is
is how do we know that so
and we don't regularly see data
dashboards and so i suppose my request
is
to help us in prioritizing our work
program
i think we should see regular data
dashboards for both health and social
care so i think that probably needs a
separate discussion around
how much detail we want and what sort of
areas of performance do we do we want to
see
because otherwise it's anecdotal it's
just yeah i think there's a problem with
access to
cams i think there is i'm pretty sure
there is but there's no data to form it
that actually shows that to me so um
that's something to consider i think for
the committee
okay thank you
any of the thoughts around the table
that's the taylor it's just to consider
if if your recommendation is that we
only take one of those topics either
access to gps or access to cams and
they've been scored equally we do need
to make a decision if i don't know what
the rest of the committee feel about
um taking those pieces of work forward
if you feel there's only really
capacity
to deliver on one of those over the
municipal year
you'd need to make a decision don't
worry as to which one we do
yes moving forward with as i understand
it we can we can do
um
one or two
um
we can't do one and two
but we could do
one or two plus
three yeah so
really it's a question of is it one or
is it two
and do we go for the third one alex you
want to say something uh there is also
the thing that the uh the second one
does also fall under the remit of the
children and young person scrutiny
committee so you could um
try and pass it on to them to look onto
or suggest a bit of
joint work and sharing resource across
the two committees
[Music]
okay well that
sort of
adds to my view that
i think the access to gps
um following the pandemic uh is still a
concern out there not just a
concern in the um
in committee such as this so i
i would like to see that one progress
if we can do that and
seek a way of progressing number two
by a slightly different route
and then take a view as to whether we
think we can manage
number
three at the same time
yeah
well we're just talking around at the
moment so it's um
by all means
give us your view on
well i'm a parent of
teenage children who've effectively been
locked in their bedrooms for two years
missing all
socialization any kind of exercise and
have become very invested in being in
the house and they and their friends are
coming out with actually terrible
problems including children that started
at university so i think mental health
for our young people is something we
really need to address because i think
we're just we're going to have problems
down the track with them certainly
and there was no suggestion that we
don't do it it's a suggestion of
how can we do it i think is the uh
if we are going to propose to look at um
at children's mental health i think it
does need to be wider as you said not
just calms its children's mental health
and well-being and just to inform the
committee as well we're already doing a
review
under um helen's leadership with the
support of aqua around children's health
and well-being in terms of their mental
health and engaging with the wider
population looking at the services we
have all the providers etcetera as well
so that that's just to give you a little
bit of context really in terms of that
and because it is wider the
the issues with any access to cams is
caused by wider issues
i was just really sort of picking up on
alex's point this is an issue that's
already on children's scrutiny list
and and i think from um health scrutiny
perhaps the adult mental health services
and aligning it to the children's work
because it is this is storing up a lot
of pressure for people um now but a lot
of
increased activity for adult services in
the future but the two things are quite
aligned and there are pressures in the
adult mental health system that are just
as big as cams
i would say
if i could be helpful here you always
are david i know
um
yeah i mean i think if a piece of work
is being done we you know
if
if
once it's done or
some kind of preparation around it
if you could keep the
committee informed of that we could then
play into it um because
no no point in duplicating uh a kind of
scrutiny piece of work
so i think that would solve the problem
[Music]
council
so do you want to follow from what davis
just said
well i
i i did but only to sort of
slightly disagree with him i think in
that
and
i think we should
we should look at the um access to child
children's mental health as a
priority i think i think the access to
gp services is important but i sort of
think
we
we sort of know what the problem is
there and we can we can still try to do
something about it um
but i think we get more value out of a
task and finished piece of work looking
at children's mental health services and
i'm saying this in the absence of data
which was the last point i made
but certainly judging by my case work
that is a major concern for residents
with some
um really serious cases of suicidal
children who are not getting access to
the help that they need okay council
brophy
so i think
there's obviously space for both these
items
and the work by our officer has been
to look at the scoring of them and they
score equally so they're both equally
worthy
so
i get the point that there's limited
resources for
this committee
and they understand about the priority
of young people
and mental health
absolutely but it's thinking about the
effectiveness of this committee and what
is best for our work and i think
just because something is sort of
far more urgent and important
as is there's nothing more important
than young person's mental health does
does it necessarily mean that
the weight of this committee is going to
make that better and if the work's
already happening in
children and young people going back to
the points that the two officers made
the two staff members made from trafford
is it something we we could look at to
do with the there's already a committee
that looks at children
and young people in trafford it's like
is there a scope for doing an overlap
committee there piece of scrutiny with
both groups because if if this committee
does it it doesn't necessarily
make things better
so i'm just trying to say that whilst i
think both things are too worthy i would
probably think the more effective piece
of work for this committee is probably
the access to gps not because it's any
less any any um
more important in fact i'd argue the
other that the young people are probably
more important but it's more about the
effectiveness of this committee
okay
well i certainly don't have the wisdom
of solomon so i am not going to try and
um impose a
so i was arguing to do both but consider
them in different ways
um
and i was just coming to that i think
what i'm
um
sensing and forgive me if i'm not
fully picking it up is this clearly an
appetite to
to do both of one and two
um
is does it make sense for us to reach
out to the children's scrutiny committee
and say we'd like you to do a joint
piece of work with us on this
um
and i would imagine they're going to say
yes
in parallel
this committee can do number one the
jeep access to gps
does that
it's definitely yeah
the children's have a
meeting on the 27th the agenda for that
goes out on
friday i'll ring the chair tomorrow and
see if she'd be happy for that proposal
to go to them for their next meeting
okay so we would have input from this
committee
on both items but it would be a joint
piece of work for the for the children's
item
[Music]
that
meet our needs are people happy with
that
well shall we go with that then
i think so
i'll stop while i think i'm winning
chair just to know that many of the
officers will be the same so any work
that can be done jointly would be really
helpful for office of time
right okay
you'll need to bring that to our
attention as to the best way of working
that yeah yeah
okay
with that uh bit concluded
um i think successfully there with some
exciting prospects of work for us to do
that
i'm going to at this
hour of the day call this meeting to a
close
but first thank everybody for their
attendance and their input
which has been uh much appreciated by me
and very helpful indeed thank you
everybody
[Music]
just something i keep something to say
to you i know we don't have that many
meetings to play with yeah but
if you
ever felt
like it would